there have been so many questions about
should you wear a mask should you not
which kind should you wear and when
should you wear them if at all the CDC
is taking steps to clear up the nation's
mask confusion all of a sudden I'm
getting very confused about whether or
not we should be wearing masks these
seem like straightforward questions but
there's a lot of gray area and a ton of
confusion so today I'm gonna be clearing
that up on April 3rd officials at the
CDC issued guidance that Americans
should wear cloth face masks when
venturing outside the home to run
essential errands now that was a big
change from recommendations a week
earlier that you only needed to wear
masks if you yourself had respiratory
symptoms like coughing or sneezing or if
you were taking care of somebody who
were sick so a couple of key things to
keep in mind the CDC is talking about
cloth face masks in addition to physical
distancing so keeping at least 6 feet
between you and others and they're still
saying stay at home as much as possible
and only head out for essential errands
the other key point the CDC is talking
about here is using the kind of cloth
mask that you can fashion yourself at
home they're not saying to use or to
hoard medical grade masks like surgical
masks or n95 respirators because those
need to be conserved for health care
workers and emergency responders if you
already have some surgical masks or n95
respirators laying around your home
that's fine you can use them but if you
have a stockpile of them then it might
be worth getting in touch with a local
health care facilities since in some
areas these are really in demand so that
leaves us with the DIY cloth face mask
now there are a ton of online tutorials
about how you can make these face masks
but I recommend going to the CDC's
website the CDC isn't simply saying that
you can tie any scarf or bandana over
your nose and mouth it's produced
tutorials like these ones so here's one
showing how you can sew a cloth face
mask at home and here's another one with
an Oso technique showing you how to fold
a piece of fabric and how to use elastic
ties or hair bands to fashion your own
cloth mask the other side then you fold
either side to the middle and you have
yourself cloth face covering it's that
easy this may seem obvious but when
you're wearing that cloth face mask
make sure it's not just covering your
mouth but it's also covering your nose
and if you wear cloth face masks when
you go out make sure when you come home
you are taking them off properly
remember do not touch the contaminated
area that's the part that covered your
mouth and your nose here and you need to
wash them regularly the CDC also says
that these homemade masks should not be
worn by kids under the age of two or
anyone who already has breathing
difficulties there are studies that show
that a cloth facemask if it's worn
correctly can limit the spread of
infectious droplets but there are some
important caveats here first off while a
cloth facemask might keep your germs in
and stop you spreading bugs to other
people it won't necessarily protect you
from becoming infected they're not good
at blocking tiny droplets in the same
way they're an n95 respirator mite and
also you'd compare a cloth master one of
those n95 and you can see that a cloth
mask does not form a tight seal around
your face there's also this concern that
wearing a cloth facemask might give some
people a false sense of security so they
put one of these homemade things on and
then they're like oh I'm just gonna go
out a lot more or I'm gonna get closer
to people than I really should so that's
one of the behaviors that we worry about
so here are my main takeaways while
there's evidence that cloth face masks
are not as effective as a medical grade
masks the CDC is saying it's better to
wear them instead of wearing nothing at
all on your face when you go out but if
you choose to wear a cloth face mask and
it is a choice because it is voluntary
guidance it has to be in addition to
physical distancing so staying at least
6 feet away from other people
maintaining good hand hygiene and only
venturing out when you absolutely need
to leave the house and when you're
wearing a mask
please don't get comfortable and assume
a cloth face mask is protecting you from
getting infected it likely isn't it's
all about keeping your germs in
and protecting others from you I hope
that answers your questions about masks
thanks for watching and send me your
questions on my social media
[Music]